hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the supreme court ruling to uphold two
republican-backed election laws in
arizona
which challengers argue will make it
harder for minorities in the
battleground state to vote
arizona attorney general mark brnovich
discusses the ruling
and how it may impact the nationwide
debate over election reform
following a year of coronavirus
restrictions plenty of americans may be
celebrating their pandemic freedom
along with independence day this holiday
weekend celebrity chef and cookbook
author paula deen
shares a few recipes you can whip up for
your barbecue
and dishes on her favorite summer meals
and her new fox nation special at home
with paula dean
paul is family cookout plus commentary
by retired marine staff sergeant
fox news contributor and host of the
proud american podcast
johnny joey jones the fox news rundown
is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you could subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm tom chalu i'm liz peake i'm charles
payne and this is the fox news
rundown
friday july 2nd 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
a major voting rights decision wrapped
up the supreme court's latest term and
the justice's divided ruling
could have far-reaching impacts arizona
law does not
disenfranchise or deter anyone you know
from voting
i mean the reality is that in arizona
there is a
plethora of ways to vote and lisa brady
you're invited to a family cookout to
celebrate the fourth of july
we've got wonderful recipes for the
grill
and outdoor cooking with celebrity chef
paula dean
and i'm marine corps staff sergeant
johnny joey jones i've got the final
word
on the fox news rundown
the supreme court upheld two of
arizona's voting laws passed in recent
years in a six to three ruling
one said with limited exceptions people
cannot turn your ballot in for you
also known as ballot harvesting the
other said ballots cast out of precinct
will not be counted
justice samuel alito wrote the majority
opinion saying that when a state
provides multiple ways to vote
any burden imposed on voters who choose
one option can't be evaluated without
considering the other ways to vote
the ruling comes at a time when
republican-led states are passing a
number of voting rule changes
the u.s attorney general is willing to
file lawsuits to stop those changes
and democrats are pushing for national
election rules we
are scrutinizing new laws that seek to
curb voter access
and where we see violations we will not
hesitate to act
we are also scrutinizing current laws
and practices
in order to determine whether they
discriminate against black voters and
other voters of color
that was attorney general merrick
garland just a couple of weeks before
filing suit against georgia over its
voting rights law
critics of arizona's laws have pointed
to the voting rights act saying these
and other rules would not have held up
if the supreme court hadn't found
section 5 of the act unconstitutional in
2013.
it had said certain states with a
history of voting discrimination had to
get pre-clearance from the federal
government
before changing their voting rules as
the president has said
we need congress to pass s-1
and the john lewis voting rights act
which would provide the department
with the tools it needs what remains
though is section two of the voting
rights act which bars discriminatory
voting practices
and in her dissent justice elena kagan
accused the majority of rewriting
section two with this arizona ruling so
what does this
ruling mean for the future of state
voting rule changes
and for the future of justice department
efforts to stop those changes
first we'll get into the arizona laws
themselves with the state's attorney
general mark brnovich
whose name is listed in the case title
and who argued the case before the
supreme court justices
himself i think it was a big win for the
constitution and it was a big win for
the rule of law
and a big win for state sovereignty
let's go back though to the ninth
circuit's ruling because they said
the motivations behind arizona's bill
were to
disenfranchise voters and they cited
statistics
um saying that hispanic and indian
residents were
more likely to rely on having someone
else take their ballot in for them
the ballot harvesting issue and that
black hispanic and native voters were
also more likely to engage in out of
precinct voting
that was the other bill what did the
supreme court
say to the ninth circuit's ruling in
when they cited these statistics
well there's a reason why the 9th
circuit historically is the most
overturned circuit
because the reality is there was a
10-day trial
here in arizona for a federal judge and
the judge ruled
that these laws were constitutional and
consistent with the voting rights act
and part of that reason is not only the
facts and evidence are presented at
trial
but the reality is a majority of states
and even the district colombia
have limits on out of precinct voting we
know that in 2005 jimmy
carter co-authored co-chaired a
commission that said
that mail-in ballots were one of the
greatest
sources of potential voter fraud so
there are states that have these kind of
common sense election integrity measures
and it's not enough for some you know
the judge on the ninth circuit sitting
in your ivory tower to
speculate and you know come up with
their own set of facts
the reality is if you want to bring a
section to voting rights claim the
supreme court said
you actually have to show this disparate
impact and you have to show
that the challenge law caused it okay
that the challenge law caused it so the
argument then is okay these statistics
may be right more people of color maybe
do engage in out
well once again if you listen i argue
the case the supreme court if you listen
to the argument
there was statistically statistical
anomalies
we submitted things that were not
statistically significant
that you couldn't show or prove or
caused by any state action
so at the end of the day the arizona
arizona law does not disenfranchise or
deter
anyone you know from voting i mean the
reality is
that in arizona there is a plethora of
ways to vote people can vote
early they can vote in person they can
vote on election day we have no excuse
absentee balloting you want to don't
want to get out of your car
we there's literally drive through
ballot locations and
contrast that with jurisdictions like
delaware connecticut new york
all these east coast states where you
have to have some bureaucrat approved
whether you want absentee voting in new
jersey the governor just touted a law
that
allows for nine days of early voting in
arizona we have three times as many days
so the reality is that there are
numerous ways that people can exercise
the franchise in arizona
and as i said during the oral argument
public servants have no more
sacred duty than protecting the people's
right to vote but
we have to maintain confidence in the
integrity of the process
and the results i i want to follow up on
that because one of the criticisms from
democrats at the time
um that these bills were being debated
was that these bills were meant to
address fraud that had not occurred that
it was just more in reaction of
fear of what might occur what
what is the fear i mean what is the fear
when it comes to ballot harvesting and
having somebody
take your vote in for you well we know
that
no less than liberal icon jimmy carter
in 2005
co-chaired a commission that said the
mail-in ballots are one of the
greatest sources of potential fraud in
2012 the new york times editorialized
about their concerns about mail into
balloting so there was a time not that
long ago
where democrats and republicans
understood that we needed to protect the
integrity of the process
and if folks on the far left really
cared or they really thought that in any
way this was
discouraging voting or disenfranchising
voters they would do something
about states like delaware or you know
new hampshire or michigan or
massachusetts all these other states
with more restrictive voting measures
so one of the fallacies that
the far left is doing or evacuating is
somehow
they think that there's an either or
choice either we have to have
more voting or we have to have voter
integrity and the reality is
they aren't inconsistent and you can
have both we can have record turnout
and we can have people being confident
the results
and that's what these common sense
election integrity measures are designed
to do
what does this ruling mean for other
voting laws being passed
at in other states and also for
arizona's
other voting laws that just recently
passed does this will this apply will
this become precedent for
other laws that have more recently
passed well i think
at the end of the day if someone wants
to bring
a claim that there's a violation of
voting rights act
they have to have facts they have to
have evidence it's as simple as that
and i think that it will mean that if if
there are states that
are truly trying to disenfranchise
voters they'll have to
you know demonstrate what they're doing
or not doing is inconsis
is consistent with the constitutional
voting rights act but at the end of the
day
this also means that i think there's
gonna be serious questions asked about
for example the biden administration's
lawsuit against georgia
you know so they're suing georgia saying
that somehow they're
disenfranchising or suppressing voters
but you know
georgia's law is more uh open and
provides more voting opportunities than
so many you know liberal states but how
much does this change the dynamic
because we know this justice department
i mean merrick garland the attorney
general has said
for weeks now we're going to be cracking
down on states where we see civil rights
violations we're going to go after them
and then after he made this big speech
about voting rights he did file suit
against georgia
um we know governor ducey in arizona has
signed um
vote voting you know laws pertaining to
voting recently
is arizona next and does this supreme
court ruling
really upend the the dynamic here as the
justice department tries to go after
states you know i can't predict
what the justice department may or may
not do
but if they read this opinion in a
serious manner
they will know that their lawsuit
against georgia
is in serious jeopardy because how are
they going to show
that you know this this statute or that
law was designed to
uh and caused an impact in voting i mean
i think they're going to have
you know a tough time doing that and
once again this case stands for the
proposition
that states can enact common sense
election integrity measures
and the reality is that you know what
works in
manhattan new york may not work in
manhattan kansas
and what works in virginia beach may not
work in redondo beach
and so the real danger and the real
threat is trying to
nationalize our elections and i think
the far left using this as some sort of
excuse
that they're going to take control of
every state's election process
one more for you mr attorney general
your name is on this case
and you personally argued before the
supreme court
now that it's over what strikes you most
about this whole experience was it
something
that happened in court was it upon
reading the ruling that you realized
something you'd said resonated like what
what is it
i think that being a first
generation american and i think when
you're you know my family fled communism
and when you have just not only
studied history but your family lived it
you have a real appreciation for how
important
our constitution is and how the united
states is different in a lot of ways in
other countries i mean this may not be a
perfect union
but we've got a system in place that
makes us the greatest country in the
world
and that system is all based on the rule
of law no matter who we are where we
come from we all get treated equally
and the fact that a first generation
american
public school kid uh you know i i'd
never run for office for the team
attorney general
could become the attorney general and
then bring a case
argue that case and win that case
is something that uh is not only
humbling to me
it's important and to me it's the
embodiment of the american dream
arizona attorney general mark vernovich
thank you so much for your time
thank you
[Music]
this is staff sergeant johnny joey jones
with your fox news commentary
coming up the pandemic's not over
but it's fair to say this fourth of july
feels a lot more like normal to many
people with coveted restrictions eased
and families able to gather once again
which often means
sharing a meal listen to this menu y'all
we're having butter burgers
tv chef author and restaurant owner
paula dean is hosting a family cookout
for her latest fox nation special
and celebrating independence day well
i'll tell you lisa
we are blessed to live on the water
she's back in familiar surroundings to
many fans her house on turner creek in
savannah georgia
which puts us in view of tybee's
fireworks
the yacht club's fireworks and if we
stand in a cert
on a certain dock uh we can even see
downtown fireworks
so we choose to stay at home
and enjoy the festivities from afar so
we get to celebrate and watch from our
home
with lots of fireworks that sounds
fantastic
lots with fireworks going all around
um i know there's a new episode um new
episode of your fox nation special is
streaming now
at home with paula deen a paula's
family cookout i'm so excited we are all
invited what can viewers expect to be
treated to
well we are actually in
our outdoor kitchen at the home that we
are now renovating to move back
into so it's been a good long while
since
people since my fans have seen that
home and that outdoor kitchen so
uh we were so glad to be able to do it
there because
people will recognize that outdoor
kitchen
and it all takes place right there on
turner's creek
and uh no fireworks though you'll be
able to hear what we're saying
um what what is that what would you say
is the highlight
of this episode i think the highlight of
this
episode is well anytime some of my
grandchildren are there that's always
the highlight
but for me but uh when we
sat down to um have our meal
it was interesting to me i took the time
to ask
each person at our table what the fourth
of july meant to them
and i have a daughter-in-law claudia
dean
bobby's wife she is from venezuela
born in venezuela and uh
when it came her turn to answer
she said opportunity and
i thought that was interesting coming
from someone that
had not had the the privilege of
growing up here in america
but coming in in her
20s uh to live here
so i thought hmm you know we all
uh all the answers were singular
from everyone at the table you know it
meant that
that um we're free to do
as we please we're we're free to
uh pursue a living uh
in fact you know i'm one of the american
dream stories
uh the fact that i could start a
business with 200
and take it to where it is now is just
amazing only in america
um but i thought
you know not every country
has the opportunities that we have
so i thought her answer was very very
interesting
that is interesting something for kind
of everyone to think about
on um independence day what what it
means to them
um i wanted to ask you about
fourth of july recipes do you have some
some favorite ones or some go-to ones i
know on this episode
you came up with a whole new one which
is mouth watering
yeah you've got to try a butter burger
i came up with that quite a few years
ago
and uh we were celebrating
everybody's birthday on one particular
sunday if their birthday was in that
month
so i wanted to do something a little
special
so i said i bet a butter burger would be
good
and it is it's just delicious
uh but you know it really depends on
whether the weather
is working with you or not i've got some
wonderful
inside recipes but if the weather is
good
we've got wonderful recipes for the
grill
and outdoor cooking what's a what's in
good easy one
um for someone who may not be a pro cook
like you
that they could do for the oil
everything that i cooked
on this special was super super easy uh
the fresh corn was wonderful
uh and the butter burgers were so easy
but
uh a recipe that i really liked
uh in this special was the scallop
potatoes
because it's cooked in a slow cooker and
just about all of our outer door places
now supplies electricity
so it was just very easy to prepare
our sides outside as it is
inside i feel like that's something
people have been doing more in recent
years too the slow cookers the air
fryers the pressure cookers
um they can they can really be time
savers do you have tips
for people who who want to use those is
there kind of a go-to thing you do to
make that easier
oh my goodness i love my pressure cooker
uh if you're cooking ribs outside you
can
put those on for about 15 or 20 minutes
in your pressure cooker
and then take them out to your grill or
if your pressure cooker is is outside
uh and that'll cut down on the length of
time it takes to cook your ribs
so um my air fryer
if my ribs don't get crispy enough to
suit me
i can throw them in my air fryer and
within 10 minutes have them crisp up
so i'm um i'm an appliance
junkie
is there when it comes to grilling is
there a common mistake
that people should avoid uh there is one
common mistake that people tend to make
while they're grilling
and that's putting their food on a too
hot a fire
you need to let your charcoal if you're
cooking on charcoal
you need to let those those uh cold turn
gray because if you if you put them
on a fire that is just blazing up
and and hot you know there's a chance
that you're gonna ruin your meat you're
gonna
burn it before it gets done so i think
that's a common mistake
that people make i really enjoy
your fox nation specials because they
always just
they always just feel good it's like
feel good listening and viewing
are you working on more of them for this
year
yes yes yes i have had so much fun doing
these specials
uh and we're working on a few more for
the rest of the year which i'm
very very excited about and
uh it's great now
that uh it was really really difficult
at first not that difficult but it was
challenging let's say
challenging because we did our filming
in-house with three of us
and a telephone wow
our first two or three specials were
shot that way
and now that that restrictions have been
lifted a little bit
the fox nation team is now coming in
and filming these and it makes it so
much easier
so much easier to have a crew here doing
it with us
instead of us shooting it on our
telephones
well the new one is streaming right now
at home with paula deen paula's family
cookout
on fox nation and we appreciate you very
much paula dean coming on the rundown
oh listen i appreciate you having me
lisa
and i hope everybody tunes in to watch
because it's
uh really a beautiful beautiful view
of turner's creek and not all of my
family could come but a good
many of my family could come it's hard
to get 24 people together at one time
so uh i hope everybody enjoys it i know
we
certainly had fun doing it for everybody
and
uh the fact that you said it it makes
you feel good to watch
that is uh that is my goal i want people
to feel like they're right there with
us feeling the love and the
companionship of family and friends
thank you paula
happy fourth thank you lisa happy fourth
to you and be
safe
[Music]
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
[Music]
powers
us military troops may be stationed
around the world but they're sending
independence day greetings back to the
states we've all heard the saying
freedom isn't free and today we're
hearing from the troops that sacrificed
to make that freedom possible
hey everyone my name is corporal hart
i'm with three meth information group
campaigns in okinawa japan just want to
wish my friends and family back in ocala
florida
happy fourth of july my name is stasar
charles ho camp at cat c camp fuji japan
i want to wish my family around the
world a very blessed independence day
hello my name is major andrew holmes i'd
like to wish all my family and friends
back stateside
a happy fourth of july and uh just want
to give a shout out to my
two daughters back stateside and my
fraternity brothers from omega sci-fi
thank you
this is lance corporal nelson aponte
stationed here at katy kanfuji japan
i just wanted to wish my wife stephanie
and our two sons rafael and ezra
for safe independence day hi i'm
lieutenant derrick van dyslund
assigned to the uss wasp and i would
like to wish my friends and family back
in brandon wisconsin
a very safe and happy fourth of july
independence day weekend
hi i'm seaman bagley assigned to the uss
wasps and i would like to wish my
friends and family back home in kansas
city kansas
a very safe and happy fourth of july
stay safe my name is senior airman
matthew allen and i want to wish
everybody and my friends and family back
in missouri
a happy fourth of july miss you and love
you and can't wait to see you
hey everyone my name is staff sergeant
john anderson i'm with fifth security
force assistance brigade
at joint base lewis mccord washington
just want to wish everyone a happy
fourth of july
hi i'm mmf and antoine assigned to the
uss wasp
and i would like to wish my friends and
family back home in bronx new york
a very safe and happy fourth of july hey
this is captain chris farnsworth from
fifth security force assistance brigade
at joyce bay's lewis record washington
do you want to wish everybody a happy
fourth of july hi i'm c.s.a mora
assigned to the uss
wasp and i would like to wish my friends
and family back in el paso texas a very
safe and happy fourth of july
my name is corporal joseph cincillo i'm
third maintenance italian mcquist
i'm ut-1 cody schwartz i'm the
headquarters of corporate town mcquist
i'm corporal benjamin both surviving and
i'm the third maintenance of time
mcquist
[Music]
happy fourth of july happy independence
day america
tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
johnny joey
what's on your mind a small distinction
to most
makes a big difference to many as a free
and prosperous country we celebrate our
independence
every year on the 4th of july
but it seems as if we almost celebrate
two different holidays
one a date on the calendar the fourth
day
in our seventh month early summer a time
to vacation
cook out go to the lake and enjoy the
gorgeous
days late into the evening the other
a reminder of the struggle to achieve
self-governance
our independence and with it
a sole responsibility for what our
country would and could become
and how we might do it most people see
our independence as a singular
act or war hundreds of years ago
yes general george washington and his
band of revolutionary fighters
sparked the flame with their muskets and
muster
that should still inspire us today but
the steady fire of freedom
has been threatened by enemies and
secured by patriots
for generations from the succession of
the southern states
to the bombing of pearl harbor to soviet
missiles in cuba
and then their horrific tragedies on
september 11 2001
every generation of americans pause in
their celebrations of freedom
in order to do the work necessary to
secure it for the next
independence and its offspring of
freedom
are the precious product of our
sacrifice and will always demand more
from us
so as you celebrate on july 4th with all
the fun
and peasantry you can handle remember
it's also
independence day a day to remember and
celebrate the many generations of
americans
who were standing watch for this great
nation
god bless and happy independence day
this is retired marine staff sergeant
and fox news contributor
johnny joey jones check out my proud
american podcast at foxnewspodcast.com
as well as the proud americans i have as
guests on my show fox nation outdoors on
the fox nation app
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily
fox on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars
it's an idea that seems a lot like
kickstarter called build it subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes